- All right, time is
almost up for this hour,
but first I wanna share one more story
to make you smile possibly.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Today is World Down Syndrome Day.
And it's all about spreading awareness
about people living with the condition.
A few years ago, a Chicago man
with Down syndrome was
on the hunt for a job
and when he couldn't find any work
he decided to take control
and launched his very own business,
creating hand painted doormats.
Check these out.
(upbeat music)
His business, This Is
Jacob, is a total success.
Now he's taken to TikTok with a new goal.
And all I can say is I'm very flattered.
- Hi guys.
Can you guys help me to go
on The Kelly Clarkson Show?
I really want to go on her show.
So please share this.
- Oh, we have Jacob on the line
along with his mama, Melanie.
How y'all doing?
What's up Jacob?
(audience cheering)
- Hi guys.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
So Melanie, tell us more about
how this all came together.
- [Melanie] So when Jacob
aged out of high school
he started looking for a job, right?
'Cause that's what you do.
And he didn't, not have very much success.
So he was getting a little discouraged
and his sister was actually looking
to have a custom mat made at
that time for their grandpa.
So Jacob said, "I think
I could make that."
And he did.
And it came out beautiful.
And shortly after that
he came up to us and said
"I wanna start my own business
and I'm gonna call it, This is Jacob."
And that's exactly what he did.
Started off making doormats
and selling them to family and friends.
And then as his business grew
through Facebook and word of mouth,
a local news station did a story on him.
And after that, his business blew up
and he's been steady ever since.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
Jacob I'm so proud of you.
This is so rad.
It is awesome
to meet you.
- [Jacob] Thank you.
- Yes I wish I could hug
you in person right now.
(laughs)
So Jacob, you donate a lot
of your profits, right?
- I do, yes to, I give away my money
to the Dear Mom Conference
and it feels good to help other
people with Down syndrome.
- Oh, that's amazing.
(audience claps)
Well you have a new mat that
you wanna show me, right?
I heard there was a mat
that you wanna show me.
- I do, yes.
- Okay, let me see it.
It's the doormat I made for you.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I will buy that from you
and have it like right
before I enter my office.
I love that.
Thank you so much, Jacob.
(audience clapping)
- You're welcome.
- And thank you Melanie.
And ma'am I don't know, your name.
What was your name in the back?
- Elise.
- Elise, thank you so much too.
You were holding it up
beautifully Vanna White.
I'm liking your post right now.
Okay, Jacob.
(bell rings)
- [Jacob] Thank you so much.
- [Melanie] Thank you so much.
- All right, well that's not all
our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of Frixion
the Go-To Erasable Pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like you, sir.
So they're going to be giving you $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- That's amazing thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] It's lovely to meet y'all.
Have a blessed day.
Thank you so much for joining us.